[Musique]
non
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je suis ravi de vous
retrouver pour cette première émission
de la saison consacrée bien entendu à la
rentrée sanitaire 4897 nouveaux cas de
kevin 19 ont été enregistrés hier dans
d'autres pays
faut-il s'en inquiéter est ce que c'est
normal et les masques obligatoire en
extérieur ou dans les entreprises est ce
que c'est vraiment nécessaire et que
sait-on de nouveaux sauts le virus se
transmet t-il par voie aérienne at-il
muté pour répondre à toutes ces
questions nous avons invité antoine
flahault qui dirige l'institut de santé
globale de l'université de genève
docteur en médecine et en bio
mathématiques épidémiologistes
professeur de santé publique vous
travaillez sur la surveillance
électronique des balles a dit sur
l'épidémiologie prévisionnel nous avons
fait deux émissions ensemble pendant le
confinement elle devait être
passionnante puisque depuis je vous vois
sur toutes les autres chaînes alors des
virus antoine flahault vous en avez vu
d'autres en quoi le vide 19 peut-il ou
doit-il nous faire peur et ce qu'il vous
fait peur avoue un titre individuel
oui il ne fait peur pour deux raisons je
dirais la première c'est que je vais sur
mes 60 ans et que j'arrive dans cette
zone à risque c'est à dire que la
commune 19 c'est pas une maladie qui
fait très peur avant 40 ans je le
reconnais mais en revanche entre 40 et
80 ans elle fait très peur et quand on a
mon âge on a en ce qui me concerne des
parents et des beaux parents qui sont
sur leurs 80 ans et leurs 90 ans et qui
sont à très haut risque pour cette
maladie c'est une maladie qui tue 20 à
40 % des personnes de plus de 80 ans
donc c'est une maladie extrêmement
dangereuse et je m'en méfie comme de la
peste
elise clément frutos médecins
infectiologues et la pitié salpêtrière
en charge de l'unité d'isolement charles
nicolle êtes l'adjointe du professeur
éric com et vous êtes la première
soignante que j'ai invité dans interdit
d'interdire pour parler du corps vide
navires us c'était il ya presque six
mois maintenant
2 mars alors vous est ce qu'il vous fait
peur ce virus
bonjour manque moi à titre personnel il
ne me fait pas peur je suis beaucoup
beaucoup plus inquiètes par la capacité
de notre pays à prévenir tester et
prendre en charge des personnes
atteintes
notre troisième invité c'est laurent
toubiana qui est épidémiologistes
docteur en physique chercheur à l'inserm
et directeur de l'irsn l'institut de
recherche pour la valorisation des
données de santé que vous avez fondé
d'ailleurs il vous fait peur avoue le
comique 19
[Applaudissements]
moi je n'ai peur de rien toute façon
donc il ne fait pas peur
en revanche je vais avoir un discours
qui risque de troubler un peu les gens
et si vous voulez la peur est très
mauvaise conseillère
c'est peut-être à ce niveau là que je me
situais mais le discours que je vais
avoir risque de troubler les gens car je
sais que beaucoup de personnes ont été
touchées par ce par ce virus ont été
malades
je pense à eux mêmes en sont morts je
pense à tous ces gens qui vont
l'entendre dire ben moi j'ai peur de
rien c'est un peu provocateur et je le
fais un peu exprès parce que je pense
aussi à tous les gens qui eux n'ont pas
connu dans leur quotidien ce virus qui
se demandent ce qui se passe et qu'ils
ont sur eux une sorte de d'épée de
damoclès qui ont peur eux et mon but ici
est d'essayer d'apporter des éléments
scientifiques pour rassurer tous ces
gens donc je n'ai pas peur et je vais
essayer de rassurer au maximum tout
toute la population ceux qui ont
souffert et ceux qui souffrent d'une
autre chose c'est-à-dire d'une d'une
sorte de d'épidémie d'anxiété c'est à
eux que je pense je les fais depuis le
début depuis le début de cette crise
j'ai envoyé à toutes les rédactions un
communiqué de presse qui permettait
justement de comprendre ce qui allait se
passer et comment ça allait se produire
jeudi que pendant une certaine période
il faudrait avoir les nerfs très solides
car le l'incidence allait augmenter
d'une manière exponentielle
mais je dis aussi que le pic serait
atteint le 1er avril et que l'épidémie
serait terminée le autour de du début
mai ce qui s'est trouvée vérifier donc
aujourd'hui nous avons des cas
sporadiques qui continue est ce assez
visible dans toutes les épidémies
je connais très bien il ya un chiffre là
que qui est tombée hier c'est celui de
que je citais tout à l'heure 4897
nouveaux cas ont été enregistrés hier
dans notre pays
alors ce chiffre là c'est comme tous les
chiffres qu'on nous d'où sort depuis le
début de cette épidémie
c'est pas forcément des chiffres
compréhensible quand ils sont tous seuls
1 4897 nouveaux cas est ce que c'est
grave
est ce que c'est normal antoine flahault
non c'est évidemment pas normal il faut
juste savoir de quoi on parle
parmi ces quatre 1897
car en fait c'est 4897 baissière ses
dires résultat le biologiques positifs
qui montrent que le virus a été
identifié chez ces personnes là un grand
nombre en fait ce sont des gens qui ont
très peu de symptômes voire même qui
sont asymptomatiques qu'ils ont été
recherchés parce qu'ils étaient des
contacts de cas dans des clusters et
c'est bien qu'on ait pu les identifier
comme positif du par ce virus
pour eux d'abord parce qu'ils savent
qu'ils sont potentiellement
contaminateur donc je pense que leur
premier réflexe est de se protéger et
protéger leurs proches protéger leurs
parents et de leurs grands parents qui
eux sont à risque si ces personnes sont
jeunes et puis avec des gens qui sont
symptomatiques mais visible
- qui n'ont pas beaucoup de symptômes
parce qu'on ne voit pas au jour
d'aujourd'hui une recrudescence très
forte des hospitalisations ou d
hospitalisation en soins intensifs
cela dit c'est extrêmement préoccupant à
mon avis parce que ça montre que le
virus continue à circuler et circuler
pas à si bas bruit que cela et que le
risque majeur c'est que il passe vers
les catégories plus âgées celles qui
sont plus à risque et qui pourrait à
nouveau être contaminés peut-être à
l'occasion de l'hiver on a vu en
australie vous savez quand l'hiver a
commencé au mois de mai c'est dans
l'hémisphère sud le début de la fin du
printemps le début de l'hiver en
australie 4 personnes simplement d'une
famille d'ailleurs qui revenait de
voyage et qu'ils étaient confinés mise
en quarantaine de façon très rigoureuse
par les australiens dans un hôtel
spécifique dédié en fait elle a
contaminé sept familles les les
personnes qui étaient les personnels de
l'hôtel légende du ménage les gardent
aussi parce qu'ils avaient même des
gardes chargés de le re de leur sécurité
et surtout de la bonne prescription de
cette quarantaine et ses gardes ces
personnes de l'hôtel sont retournés dans
leur communauté ont infecté leurs
proches des écoles ont connu une
épidémie d épidémie puis après les
maisons de retraite
ce que vous appelez les ehpad en france
il également connu des épidémies une
forte mortalité et ça a été tellement
difficile à contrôler que l'état de
victoria a décidé de confiner très
strictement avec un couvre feu très très
durement un peu comme la france l'a
connu cet hiver et c'était leur deuxième
confinement ils ont eu un deuxième
confinement d'une ville de cinq millions
d'habitants
donc je pense que deuxième vague
malheureusement à la faveur de l'hiver
et de cette circulation pour l'instant
qui se passe de façon très bénigne dans
les classes les plus jeunes de la
société pourrait malheureusement nous
engendrer une seconde vague hivernale et
c'est vraiment à cela qu'il faut
s'attaquer il faut vraiment tout faire
pour éviter ce type de seconde vague
l'histoire australienne semble bien se
terminer parce que comme l'a dit laurent
toubiana
faut avoir une pensée pour tous ceux qui
ont souffert et même qui sont décédés
dans cette vague australienne
mais aujourd'hui l'épidémie est sous
contrôle et il semble que les choses
soient à peu près revenu à la normale
dans la région de melbourne et dans
toute l'australie à un coût très élevé à
nouveau lise clément frutos oui c'était
une petite clarification on entend
souvent dans les médias à tort il ya eu
tant de nouvelles contaminations en
france
hier aujourd'hui donc ce ne sont pas des
nouvelles contaminations ce sont des
gens qui ont réussi à se faire dépister
qui se trouve être positif pour un cas
dépistés positifs il peut y avoir dix
fois cent fois plus de nouvelles
contaminations
donc ça fait c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que bon ben voilà
on a connu ce pic épidémique assez
classique dans une transmission
interhumaine aux alentours du 15 avril
puis la décroissance qu'on connaît on se
voit là on pensait pas que ça allait
totalement disparaître maintenant à
faire un virus transmission interhumaine
un niveau d'immunité très faible aux
alentours de 10% dans notre pays donc on
n'a pas fini d'en entendre parler
néanmoins on s'attend pas à voir une
deuxième vague de la même ampleur la
première on s'attend plutôt à voir un
niveau dans des mii cité avec des
nouveaux pics qui seront à des
probablement à des niveaux inférieurs à
la première vague donc plusieurs petites
vagues si vous voulez
et cela tient au fait que quand même il
ya plus de mesures barrières dans notre
pays que déjà beaucoup de personnes
malheureusement ils en sont décédés et
que petit à petit les immunités oriente
laurent toubiana vous disiez tout à
l'heure le pic c'était en avril en mai
l'épidémie était terminé alors aux dix
bals
si l'épidémie est terminée pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a des masques pourquoi on
nous annonce autant de nouveaux cas
chaque jour vous vous répondez quoi je
réponds qu'il ne vous a pas échappé que
cette épidémie était un peu spécial il y
a eu beaucoup d'informations sur cette
épidémie c'est à dire une une une
avalanche de chiffres
cette avalanche de chiffres véhiculés le
sans précaution donne si vous voulez
amplifie les peurs et si je viens vous
parler c'est justement pour tenter avec
tous mes doutes tenter d'expliquer ce
que sont ces chiffes alors nous avons
mis en place récemment un peu après la
bataille
un système de détection absolument
faramineux
ce système de détection c'est le
déploiement sur toute la france
deux centres de prélèvement et ses
centres de prélèvement permettent de
faire des tests et 7 est le dise si la
personne est porteuse ou pas ce système
de détection nous ne l'avions pas à
l'époque de du pic épidémique et même du
de la première vague épidémique
nous n'avions pas ça donc nous ne
pouvions pas aller voir c'est ces cas là
et c'est ce que j'ai appelé dans un
message cycle la matière noire
vous savez que je suis je suis je suis
astrophysiciens en fait et est donc en
astrophysique
il existe ce qu'on appelle la matière
noire c'est ce que l'on ne peut pas
détecter on sait que c'est là mais on ne
peut pas le détecter et bien par par jeu
j'avais dit ben on a une sorte de deux
de masse qu'on n'arrive pas à cerner ce
sont tous ces cas qui que l'on ne voit
pas ce que l'on voyait à l'époque
c'étaient des dca malades
c'était des gens qui arrivaient à
l'hôpital ou qu'ils allaient voir les
médecins en première ligne et c'est ces
gens là qu'on capte le conte
comptabilisé on n'avait pas d'autre
moyen de savoir qu'il y avait dans la
population un virus qui circule est donc
nous nous avons fait des calculs
s'appelle des rétros calcul et qui
permettait de savoir quelle était
l'ampleur de cette ce nombre inconnu de
personnes et il se trouve que ce ces
calculs ne sont publiés et donner plus
de dix fois le nombre le nombre de mains
de malades mais on ne pouvait pas les
voir aujourd'hui on les voit mais il
n'ya plus de malades
si vous regardez si vous voulez je vais
vous montrer des cours de la ici je vais
tenter de démontrer voit donc ici
alors voilà là c'est c'est la courbe des
des corses appellent des cas confirmés
voilà les cas confirmés est là en orange
vous voyez le premier pic c'est le pic
épidémique
et puis en ce moment ce qu'on voit c'est
une remontée ici de cas confirmés mais
ces gens ne sont pas tant des choses des
soucis ma feuille mais voilà et donc je
prends l'autre feuilles qui aida loops
effectivement ne vont pas en réanimation
et ne exactement lorsque vous voyez ici
la courbe en rouge ici ce sont la cus et
la courbe des malades et ceux que l'on
voit ici en face
et bien c'est qu'il n'y a pas de malade
donc nous sommes face à une épidémie où
il y a des gens porteurs asymptomatiques
mais il n'y a pas de malade il n'y a pas
de malade dit n'y a pas de morts donc
une épidémie s'en va là des 100 morts
c'est un petit peu compliqué à
comprendre mais en tout cas ça fait très
très peur et ça participe si vous voulez
à la à l'anxiété générale de la
population
et voilà je tente de les rassurer par ce
genre de choses alors on va pouvoir
discuter de tout ça un probablement avec
le professeur antoine flahault
mais voilà ce que nous nous constatons
c'est ces données sont disponibles en
ligne tout le monde peut les lire
et pour ce qui concerne les
hospitalisations
alors ça date du 23 vous voyez donc
c'était hier c'est 3-2 hospitalisation
pardon il ya ilahi à 383 personnes
hospitalisées en ce moment en france et
je crois qu'il y en ait deux ou trois de
plus ce médaillon le voilà voilà
383 en réanimation et les nouveaux
patients réalisé animations sont 6
uniquement
est ce que vous êtes d'accord antoine
flahaut et élise clément frutos et
lisent mon service donc une petite
correction je ne suis plus en charge de
l'unité d'isolement charles nicolle sauf
que là pendant les suit à l'intérim
pendant les vacances
néanmoins dans l'unité
kovy des maladies infectieuses à la
pitié salpêtrière on a une quinzaine de
patients actuellement on a eu un décès
la semaine dernière deux transféré en
réanimation et on a un patient un petit
peu en fin de vie actuellement mais pour
d'autres raisons qui agit donc c'est sûr
que par rapport à un mois d'avril où il
y avait 400 un patient sur l'hôpital et
plusieurs décès par jour
voilà on en n'est pas là il ya quand
même un risque pour les plus vulnérables
toujours tant que le virus circule il ya
quand même toujours à risque
antoine flahault oui alors c'est
intéressant parce qu'on a retrouvé la
même chose que ce que laurent toubiana a
montré par ses modèles de rétro calcul
au moment du mois de mars nous fait part
d enquête de séroprévalence à dire qu'on
a regardé les taux d'anticorps chez les
habitants du canton de genève dans un
sur un échantillon représentatif des
habitants du canton de genève et on a pu
s'apercevoir qu'en effet une seule
personne sur dix étaient apparues dans
la veille sanitaire donc c'est pareil
finalement à genève que en france neuf
sur dix était passé au travers des
mailles du filet et en effet je suis
assez d'accord avec l'idée
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu ces
notes flatte que l'on probablement pas
tous les neuf d'ailleurs mais c'est dans
ce réservoir là qu'aujourd'hui on puise
le cette circulation du virus chez des
gens très très très peu symptomatiques
ou voire complètement asymptomatiques
alors ce qui n'est pas complètement
rassurant c'est que parce qu on aurait
pu avoir une disparition de la
circulation du virus
ce que dit aussi laurent toubiana et
qu'il me semble vrai c'est que on a un
dispositif totalement inédit de mesure
en europe de ces de ces vieux de la
circulation de ces virus
dans le fond on n'a jamais fait au mois
d'août 125000 pcr en france par jour où
cent mille cent vingt-cinq minutes crois
que c'était hier où avant-hier ou cent
mille aujourd'hui pcr par jour pour
regarder par exemple si le virus de la
grippe circulent et je ne dis pas
d'ailleurs qui circulent mais je n'en
sais rien en fait on n'a jamais
une telle ampleur de test et cette
ampleur de tests montrent que le virus
le corona virus continue à circuler
alors c'est pas pour nous plaire parce
que la situation européenne qui est un
peu paradoxal c'est à dire qu'avec
beaucoup de cas confirmés qui comme cela
a été répété à la fois par et élise
clémence frutos et par laurent toubiana
sont des cas très très très léger pour
la plupart d'entre eux est encore une
fois il ya bien sûr quelques uns qui
vont quand même des complications et qui
doivent être prises en charge comme vous
l'avez montré chaque jour il y en a de
nouveau mais c'est extrêmement faibles
numériquement et bien cette situation
inédite est les retrouverez dans
beaucoup de pays d'europe de l'ouest on
la retrouve en suisse on la retrouve en
espagne on la retrouve aux pays bas on
la retrouve pas tellement en allemagne
on commence à la retrouver en italie
mais on ne la retrouve pratiquement
nulle part ailleurs dans le monde c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui aux états unis
encore la circulation du virus qui
concerne à la fois les jeunes et les
personnes âgées fait une très forte
mortalité
et je ne parle pas de l'amérique latine
il ya des pays comme le perron par
exemple qui vivent une situation
absolument alarmante
aujourd'hui en termes de morbidité et de
mortalité et de deux je dirais de deux
d'engorgement de son système de santé
donc c'est de cela dont on veut se
prévenir et on ne peut que se féliciter
qu'aujourd'hui on y arrive qu'on a des
hôpitaux très serein très calme et c'est
cela qu'il faut absolument à tout prix
je crois préserver et je crois que ces
mesures barrières que l'on nous impose
que dont on voudrait bien se débarrasser
rapidement ces mesures barrières elles
ont aujourd'hui un but qui est de
maintenir cette situation le plus
longtemps possible et de ne surtout
jamais revivre ce que dans la pub pivot
où ce que certains pays vivent en ce
moment
en même temps on a des parfois des
injonctions contradictoires on se dit
faut-il la voir ou ne faut-il pas
l'avoir ce virus on insiste sur le fait
que très peu de gens l'ont eu
et pour cause n'ayant ni masque ni test
ni méthode de traçage nous avons confiné
les populations et c'était le meilleur
moyen d'arrêt
tu es que ou en tout cas de freiner la
circulation du virus
maintenant que nous sommes ressortis des
confiné on s'aperçoit que le virus
circule toujours
et on vient c'est dommage il faudrait
qu'ils aient 60 ou 70% de la population
qu'il ait eu pour qu'on atteigne une
immunité collective
alors encore une fois est-ce qu'il faut
la voir où est ce qu'il ne faut pas de
la voir votre patron le professeur comme
élise a dit blanc après tout les jeunes
laissons les se contaminer et
immédiatement tout le monde a hurlé
alors qu'en est il exactement est ce que
il faut la voir où est ce qu'il ne faut
pas la voir élise c'est pas c'est pas
comme ça que je verrai les choses et
qu'il faut la voir ou pas la voir là
actuellement comme disait mon cher
collègue on peut pas on peut pas arrêter
les mesures barrières effectivement les
jeunes ne sont pas à risque de formes
sévères ou très peu s'ils restent entre
eux il n'y a aucun souci
le problème c'est que un moment donné
peuvent rentrer en contact avec des
personnes vulnérables et les contaminer
donc aujourd'hui je crois qu'il faut
vraiment être pragmatique on n'a encore
pas de vaccin efficace
on n'a pas de d'immunité collective et
le et le virus n'est pas partie
contrairement aux ars cauvin ou homère
score qui sont d'autres coronavirus
mortels qui ont disparu assez rapidement
de la circulation celui-là est toujours
là et on peut craindre qu'il soit encore
là jusqu'en 2021 et peut-être même en
2022 si on n'attire pas de vaccin
efficace
donc tant qu'on est dans un niveau de
circulation active comme c'est le cas
actuellement dans d'autres pays il faut
maintenir les mesures barrières
donc oui je sors de chez moi j'ai un
masque sur le visage
j'ai dans ma poche droite un masque de
rechange au cas où mon masque est
mouillé ou ou ne ne fonctionne plus et
j'ai dans la poche gauche
ma petite fiole de de solutions hydro
alcooliques pour me désinfecter les
mains quand je rentre dans un transport
en commun ou dans un magasin surtout si
je vais être amené à toucher des choses
dans le magasin donc voilà ça c'est bien
sûr là il faut
il faut les conserver cet automne cet
hiver probablement jusqu'au printemps
et d'ailleurs les autres virus qui ont
pas l'air de circuler encore comme la
grippe on n'a pas actuellement des cas
de grippe vont bientôt apparaître
donc ça sera l'occasion d'être efficace
également sur sa nous voilà soyons
prudents on n'a pas la capacité en
france de tester suffisamment de
patients même si on arrive % vitesse par
jour il ya encore beaucoup de gens qui
n'arrivent pas à se faire dépister et on
n'a pas non plus la capacité d'absorber
une vague trop importante
on l'a vu la première fois leur toubib
anna oui j'adhère totalement est à 100%
à ce qui vient d'être dit c'est à dire
les mesures barrières doivent être
effectivement maintenu il ne faut pas
confondre
il ne faut pas qu'il y ait d'ambiguïté
sur mon message on met ça je n'ai pas de
dire c'est la débandade allez-y vous
pouvez y aller loin de là je considère
au contraire que l'hygiène et quelque
chose d'élémentaire en période
épidémique
évidemment non mais dans toutes les
périodes c'est à dire que la distance
sociale
d'une manière générale les l'hygiène des
mains
tout ça fait partie d'un des grands
progrès de l'humanité note progrès l'un
des progrès majeurs de l'humanité
l'humanité c'est justement ce ce type
d'hygiène donc évidemment je vais pas
dire je vais pas dire le contraire
etc etc en revanche pour ce qui concerne
la fin d'une épidémie moi je me suis
beaucoup posé de question c'est comment
se termine les épidémies par exemple il
faut savoir que les épidémies sont sont
finalement suivent un système qui s'est
cassé connu qui s'appelle la diffusion
des innovations un virus c'est une
innovation et ça se diffuse dans la
population
exactement comme comme une mode si vous
voulez
vous voyez les modes il y a un début les
tout premiers points toutes premières
personnes qui ont touché puis après ça
devient ça devient exponentielle les
gens sont prennent rencontre la mode et
puis au bout d'un moment ça disparaît
bien on a remarqué que les et les
épidémies fonctionner de la même manière
et lorsqu'on fait une étude de sueur sur
toute la planète on nous avons fait ça
nous avons réalisé ce travail qui lui
aussi a été publié c'était de regarder
la dynamique de cette épidémie d'une
manière spatio temporelle et nous nous
sommes aperçus que partout dans le monde
le la dynamique de l'épidémie était
rigoureusement la même
alors bien sûr vous avez des pays qui ne
sont pas comparables
lorsque vous comparez la france et les
états unis vous voyez bien que
géographiquement la population n'est pas
répartie du tout de la même manière et
donc les choses peuvent pas apparaître
différentes mais lorsqu'on fait un
travail un peu plus fin on s'aperçoit
que cette cette épidémie se propage
exactement de la même manière partout et
notamment une chose très très
remarquable c'est indépendamment des
mesures prises c'est à dire que lorsque
l'on regarde par exemple ce qui s'est
passé pour la suède qui n'a pas ce que
la suède est un exemple un incroyable
c'est à dire que tout le monde avait
choisi le confinement par exemple la
suède ne l'a pas choisi eh bien on
s'aperçoit que la dynamique de sa courbe
de mortalité c'est ce qui est important
à la mortalité quand même dans dans une
épidémie c'est c'est extrêmement
important c'est un marqueur fort et bien
la courbe épidémique de mortalité en
suède est rigoureusement la même que
partout ailleurs
voilà ça c'est bien là une obligé de
vous interrompre mais juste une pause on
se retrouve juste après en continu ce
débat
[Musique]
c'était une figure nationale il était
connu à l'époque
quels étaient les grands aspects de sa
personnalité gouda de la sablière donc
sera un des plus grands généraux donc de
division de la grande armée et ce
général il sera toujours fidèle
fidèle à la révolution aussi fidèle à
languir
et s'il n'est pas populaire il est
respecté ça sans aucun problème et
lorsque il va être atteint boulet de
canon le 19 août 1812
ça va être une grande perte aujourd'hui
français et russes main dans la main
pour retrouver les ossements du général
ghislain comment diplomatiquement cette
découverte résonne tel par mois je pense
qu'elle arrive au au meilleur moment
parce que je pense que les liens entre
la russie et la france ont des liens
historiques
entre 800 et 1000 tonnes de fuel se sont
déversés dans les eaux turquoises
mauricienne ce qu'il faudrait étendre
l'enquète aux autorités portuaires voir
plus haut
une fois nous devons maintenant établir
la chaîne de responsabilités nationales
il faut savoir que la partie arrière du
bateau contient encore environ 50 à 100
tonnes de fuel donc ça pourrait aussi
actuellement se fracasser et causé un
deuxième déversement de pétrole plus ça
arrive
après les communes 19 avons secteur
hôtelier et touristique est à genoux
ossements des impacts de la catastrophe
sur l'environnement marin mais aussi sur
les populations niveau de la santé
devront se faire ressentir pendant des
décennies il faut s'attendre aujourd'hui
à maurice aussi un désastre sanitaire
il est catastrophe on aura vécu voilà
pourquoi je suis pas si pessimiste que
c'est
[Musique]
nous voilà de retour sur le plateau d'
interdit d'interdire avec antoine
flahault qui est directeur de l'institut
de santé globale est l université de
chevenez avec élise clément fructose qui
est infectiologues ses adjointes du
professeur comme à la pitié salpêtrière
et laurent toubiana qui est
épidémiologistes et docteur en physique
directeur de l'irsn l'institut de
recherche pour la valorisation des
données de santé est ce que ça fait six
mois maintenant que ce virus circule en
tout cas dans notre pays
et qu'est ce qu'on apprend encore sur
lui certaines régions de l'espagne
interdisent maintenant de fumer à
l'extérieur
prétextant que ça se transmet très par
la fumée
un juge a cassé la décision a madrid on
peut de nouveau fumée mais mais ça reste
vrai dans différentes régions de
l'espagne
de même on s'est beaucoup interrogé pour
savoir s'il se transmettait dans l'air
par voie aérienne par aérosol ce creux
ce coronavirus alors qu'en est il
exactement antoine flahault aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on peut dire que le virus se
transmet pas les aérosols
c'est à dire pas seulement par ses
boutet tous ces micro gouttelettes qui
nous sortent de la bouche ou du nez mais
aussi comme ça dans l'air alors
aujourd'hui ce que l'on peut dire c'est
que c'est une maladie qui se transmet
principalement par ces gouttelettes de
postillons qu'on aimait quand on tousse
quand on parle d'ailleurs quand on l'a
il se trouve que quand on chante par
exemple ou quand on crée un peu fort ces
gouttelettes deviennent des
microgouttelettes c'est à dire qu'elles
sont fractionnées dans notre gorge et
elle flottait dans l'air un peu plus
longtemps
c'est ça les aérosols les aérosols c'est
pas du virus tout sonne ces deux virus
qui est porté par une gouttelette un
tout petit peu plus petit tellement plus
petite que la gravité n'agit pas
immédiatement et qu'elle peut voler dans
l'air du coup la fameuse distance
physique de
m 50 de 2 mètres qui est préconisée et
qui est tout à fait suffisantes pour les
gouttelettes de postillons que nous
émettons régulièrement et qui est très
efficace pour ces gouttelettes parce
qu'ils retournent sur le sol en revanche
ces micro gouttelettes pince
potentiellement nous affecter ce que
l'on pense aujourd'hui avec le le
secours aux navires us parce que
l'épidémiologie ne nous montre pas non
plus beaucoup beaucoup de clusters qui
serait due à la climatisation ou à la
circulation dans les ventilation
mécanique assistée par exemple de ces
micro gouttelettes on peut penser que la
voie principale reste les gouttelettes
deux postillons
qui donc pour beaucoup cette fameuse
distance physique de un mètre cinquante
à deux mètres est suffisante
et puis que dans des milieux très clos
très confiné où il ya très peu de
ventilation alors ces petites
gouttelettes en suspension
lorsqu'il en particulier dans les
atmosphères un peu bondée où il ya
beaucoup de gens les open space où il y
aurait beaucoup de gens alors on peut se
faire contaminer aussi c'est aussi une
voie de transmission
enfin il ya une troisième voie de
transmission qui est le fait que ces
gouttelettes elle retourne quelque part
parfois leur tombe sur une surface plane
sur votre smartphone sur un clavier
d'ordinateur sur une poignée de porte et
il peut y avoir en théorie une
contamination par c'est pas parce et je
dirais projections sur les surfaces
planes
cela dit c'est probable d'abord ça
jamais été véritablement démontré c'est
pas facile à le faire et que qui est des
contaminations de cette façon là et
probablement c'est une voie très mineur
la voie principale est en scène des
gouttelettes leurs comptes à reprendre
cette histoire de de fumée alors oui
quand on fume on exhale des particules
fines qui sont des particules fines de
pollution un petit peu comme les
particules fines du diesel d'ailleurs
alors il a été
évoquée comme hypothèse que peut-être
ces particules fines pourrait fixer le
virus s'était très hypothétique et puis
pour que ce virus fixé sur une
particules fines au hasard d'une
rencontre entre la micro gouttelettes
très très fine et la particules fines et
qu'elle soit en plus affectueuse pour
vous parce qu'il faut pas croire que
parce que vous vous inhalez un seul
virus
vous allez faire l'infection il faut une
dose de charge suffisante qui est pas
très connu d'ailleurs
donc je pense que franchement la
probabilité du fumeur qui vous infecte
par la part ça fumait être très faible
la seule chose qui pourrait peut-être se
faire je dirais qui sur le plan de la
théorie ne satisferaient un peu plus
c'est un fumeur qui lui-même est malade
alors lui il va rentrer dans ses poumons
où il a peut-être des petits foyer de
pneumonie avec beaucoup de virus et il
va exhaler des particules qui pourraient
tout contaminés peut-être lui en effet
pourrait être un petit peu plus
contaminant qu'un autre 70' l' hypothèse
je sais pas ce qu'en pensent mes
collègues là-dessus encore une fois ce
sont des hypothèses même si elles sont
un jour démontré en laboratoire pour
montrer que véritablement savage joue un
rôle important dans la contamination
à mon avis il en faut beaucoup campent
ans élise clément frutos et puis
question puisque vous parlez de fumeurs
on a dit beaucoup que les fumeurs
étaient plus résistants au virus et que
finalement ils faisaient du mouret moins
du duc vide que les autres est ce que
vous l'avez constaté lise thériault free
qui s'est attirée la parole oui c'est à
vous je me posais la question oui bon
première chose fût mais fumer du tabac
est à déconseiller de mauvais pour la
santé
donc si vous n'avez pas encore arrêté de
fumer
c'est peut-être l'occasion d'autre part
oui il ya eu d'ailleurs à la pitié
l'impression sur une cohorte que le
tabac pourrait être protecteur ça n'a
pas été publié ni confirmer encore
actuellement
et donc voilà comme disait mon collègue
la transmission est principalement par
les gouttelettes mais il ya quand même
un risque d'aérosols et c'est pour ça
que on encourage voilà à ouvrir les
fenêtres à aérer les espaces le plus
possible en tout vienne à moi je dirais
qu'une seule chose fumée q c'est tout
j'ai jugé
si vous voulez je travaille avec les
centre de tabacologie depuis quelques
années j'ai l'ensemble des bases de
données en france
fumer ça tu vois là ça tu tellement que
fumer tue deux fois plus tous les ans
que ce cas tu es le le comique 19 et ça
il faut avoir ce sera en tête aussi ça
c'est un bon indicateur
c'est que tous les ans on tue deux fois
plus de monde par le tabac que ce cas tu
es le colis de 19 alors maintenant bien
sûr les aérosols sont quelque chose
qu'on connaît bien le professeur antoine
flahault connaît très bien les
gouttelettes de flügel puisque c'est
comme ça globalement que se transmet
quoi c'est un des vecteurs de la grippe
les aérosols sont
se propage et reste en l'air dans les
milieux confinés
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
l'une des raisons pour laquelle il y en
a beaucoup d'autres à c'est
multifactoriel
mais l'une des raisons pour laquelle en
hiver lorsqu'on vit dans des espaces
confinés
il y a en général une grande probabilité
qu'arrivent des épidémies de grippe et
ces épidémies de grippe bizarrement
lorsqu'on ouvre les fenêtres lorsqu'on
essaye d'aérer l'espace est bien le
risque est moins grand alors j'aimerais
justement revenir sur cet aspect là
puisque l'inde est l'un des aspects de
cette crise a été justement ce qu'on a
appelé le confinement et à un moment
donné donc pendant la crise on nous a
dit il faut vous confiné et bien
probablement que ce confinement a
sûrement joué un facteur accélérateur de
la propagation du virus
en tout cas intra familiales voilà donc
il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'incohérences dans cette gestion de
crise
ce que j'aimerai toujours apporté c'est
un message d'espoir c'est que j'ai pour
ma part l'impression que une grande
partie de la population a été exposé à
ce virus
c'est une hypothèse forte je le sais
cette exposition a été fulgurante
très rapide a touché un très grand
nombre de de gens mais très peu de gens
ont été malades
les gens qui ont été malades ce sont des
gens qui étaient déjà en état de
faiblesse de santé et si il y à une
sorte de constat si vous voulez dans
dans la population de ces fameux jeunes
dont on parle et qu'on
qu'on stigmatise quelque part et ça me
fait beaucoup de peine pour ça parce que
ces jeunes ne constate pas dans leur
expérience quotidienne
ce feu ce problème là mais ça ne veut
pas dire pour autant que lorsqu'ils vont
voir leur leurs grands parents
il ne se protègent pas à ce moment là il
ne protège pas leurs grands-parents donc
lorsqu'ils sont entre eux ils ont
peut-être le coc vide
ok ils sont porteurs mais ils ne sont
pas malades et la conscience l'effort
que l'on doit faire c'est surtout sur
les risques
ensuite lorsqu'ils sont proches de
personnes à risque et ça c'est connu les
personnes à risque sont connus et bien
là il faut probablement à voir si vous
voulez une une méthode pour expliquer le
mieux possible ça et si les gens
comprennent ils probablement ils
adopteront l'attitude plutôt que des
méthodes plus ou moins coercitives qui
oblige les gens sont comprendre ce
qu'ils font antoine flahault
je pense que il ya deux il ya une
caricature qu'il ne faut pas faire c'est
le propos qui a été fait peut-être un
peu trop souvent ce à propos de la suède
j'ai entendu laurent toubiana dire ils
n'ont pas confiné en suède c'est à mon
avis très faux parce que je pense qu'à 2
il ya deux plans très différents
le confinement à mon avis et puis je
pense que beaucoup de publications le
montre a été d'une très grande
efficacité lorsqu'il a été appliquée tôt
et lorsqu'il était appliquée longtemps
pour réduire cette épidémie la seule
chose c'est que ça n'est pas le
confinement strict qui a une valeur
ajoutée par rapport au confinement plus
participatif
la suède a énormément confiné mais a
confiné de façon très participative en
faisant confiance à sa population parce
que aussi la population suédoise est une
population inquiète très haut niveau de
culture de santé publique
les indicateurs de santé en suède sont
parmi les plus élevés
monde la suède a conscience dans son
gouvernement
et quand le gouvernement dit rester à la
maison les suédois restent à la maison
pour vous dire jamais il y a eu une
interdiction aux compagnies aériennes de
volée de faire voler les vols
domestiques et pourtant pendant le
confinement de cet hiver les vols
domestiques se sont arrêtés les
compagnies ont arrêté leur vol pourquoi
parce qu'il y avait plus de clients tout
simplement jamais on a dit vous devez
n'être qu'à un kilomètre de votre
domicile
les suédois pouvait partir il a fait un
très beau week-end à un pack à stockholm
il aurait pu partir sur la côte ouest
les autoroutes ont eu 90 % de trafic
autoroutier en moins spontanément les
gens sont restés chez eux les bars les
restaurants sont en effet restés ouverts
et ils avaient une influence de 25% de
l'affluence habituelle
donc si vous voulez il ya eu un
confinement qui que j'appellerais un
auto confinement en suisse ou en
allemagne nous avons eu un confinement
qui était que nous nous appelons le
semis confinement c'est à dire que
l'économie a été elle aussi très
fortement impacté on a en effet fermer
les commerces non essentiels comme vous
en france mais on ne nous a jamais
demandé la moindre autorisation pour
sortir de chez nous pour on pouvait même
traversé tout le pays
je peux vous dire que personne ne
traversait le pays qu'on a tous fait du
télétravail qu'on a tous véritablement
était confiné chez nous et que grâce à
ça ça eu une très très très grande
efficacité
c'est à dire que les pays qui ne l'ont
pas le fait les états unis sont morts
beaucoup les doigts ce sont des pays
comme les etats unis comme beaucoup
d'état des états unis qui d'ailleurs
même la californie ne le fait pas
aujourd'hui et connaît une très très
forte mortalité est donc je pense qu'il
ya une grande irresponsabilité
aujourd'hui à ne pas reconnaître que le
confinement et je ne dis pas le
confinement strict je ne dis pas
l'assignation à résidence qui est
peut-être en effet terriblement forte
mais le confinement ce qui réduit le
nombre de contacts entre les gens est
une mesure d'une très très grande
efficacité
je dirais presque un peu malheureusement
parce que ce sera larmes d'ultime
secours
si jamais nous avions à faire face à une
seconde vague je préfère bien sûr que
nous fassions tout en prenant les
masques
le télétravail la distanciation social
le lavage des mains pour éviter qu'on
retombe dans un autre confinement les
éléments frutos beaucoup de gens alors
certains appellent à un nouveau
confinement d'autres le redoute
aujourd'hui que nous avons en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on nous dit des masques des
tests et même des méthodes de traçage
est-ce que c'est imaginable qu'on se
concevoir confiné pour vous ça pourrait
arriver si effectivement les mesures ne
sont pas prises donc c'est très très
importante que vient de dire antoine
flahault
il faut qu'il y ait une relation de
confiance entre l'état et la population
si l'état fait ce qu'il faut la
population qui a extrêmement bien
compris ce qui se passait ce qu'il
fallait faire fera ce qu'il faut faire
voilà c'est chacun chacun jouera sa
partie peut-être toujours une infime
portion de la population qui qui sera en
rébellion et voilà qu'il faudra éduquer
mais mais la grande majorité des grandes
majeure partie des gens a compris ce
qu'il fallait faire par contre ce qu'ils
demandent à leur gouvernement c'est de
pouvoir se protéger donc de mettre des
masques à disposition surtout les
populations a le plus à risque
finalement ce sont les populations
précarisées on a énormément de patients
qui nous viennent pas seulement d pad
mais de foyers d'accueil etc
donc il faut que les masques foie gras
gratuit à disposition dans ces
structures
et puis il faut que les gens qui le
souhaitent puissent se faire dépister
même ceux qui n'ont pas forcément de
titre de séjour en vigueur et voilà donc
si le gouvernement ce qui puisqu'il faut
avec une capacité de 2 piquetage de
toutes les personnes qui le souhaitent
et peut-être on en parlera après avec
d'autres méthodes de dépistage un petit
peu moins invasive est un petit peu
moins lourde et que les gens voient là
se sentent en confiance ils feront ce
qu'ils font ce qu'il faut et si les gens
ne font pas ce qu'il faut on risque
effectivement d'avoir une vague la
prochaine vague assez importante qui
nous oblige
la coercition et qui nous obligent à
recombiner ce qui serait vraiment
quelque part un échec
et ça ce serait dans le cas où de
nouveaux les urgences seraient débordés
ou les
il n'y aurait plus assez de deux places
en réanimation on est bien d'accord
c'est ça c'est pas le nombre de nouveaux
cas qui doit nous alarmer mais
uniquement le nombre d'hospitalisations
éventuellement et de gens en réanimation
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec tout
ça le rôle d'anna bien écoutez je suis
ravi d'entendre antoine flahault sûr sur
cette affaire de confinement suédois de
confinement je trouve ça fantastique ce
glissement sémantique c'est à dire que
en gros il y aurait une forme d'auto
d'autodiscipline en suède que nous
n'avons pas donc nous on est obligé de
mettre les gens finalement sous clé avec
avec amende si on se déplace on
surveille toute la population vous
comprenez que c'est un peu un peu dur à
avaler ce genre de choses mais mais mais
pourquoi pas si vous voulez il ya juste
un tout petit détail c'est que le
bénéfice risque de la suède et de la
france n'est pas du tout au même niveau
puisque la france de la france a
pratiquement arrêtées sont ok son
économie ce qui n'est pas du tout le cas
de la suède et puis en plus on a fait
peser pendant de très nombreuses
semaines
cette espèce de 2,2 d'enfermement sur
les gens et d'angoua si vous voulez
qu'ils étaient extrêmement difficiles à
supporter donc voila moi je je
j'entends le nombre de personnes qui se
sont figés qui ont été en kz2 les
psychoses qui se sont développées tout
cela me semble extrêmement grave et en
plus contrairement à ce que dit antoine
il est incapable de démontrer que ce
confinement a fonctionné et j'aimerais
simplement il y a à l'heure actuelle
énormément de papier qui sortent sur ce
point il y as énormément d'arguments qui
vont dans le sens de la démonstration
que ce confinement n'a pas servi et je
vais en donner un seul l'a tout de suite
dans le confinement
il y avait 1 on avait un paquet cadeau
s'ils voulaient effectivement on coupait
les contacts entre les gens c'est l'idée
mais j'ai rappelé tout à l'heure que
confiné les gens permettait aussi au
virus de se développer d'une manière
intrafamiliales donc on coupe les
contacts ce que antoine flahault me dis
qu'en suède ça se fait tout seul donc ça
s'est très très bien mais ce qui se
passe c'est que le paquet cadeau c'est
que lorsqu'on relâche et le confinement
étant donné que la population n'était
pas immunisé et que le virus circule est
tout de suite toujours il y aurait dû
avoir normalement une reprise de
l'épidémie puisque on revenait
exactement au même niveau et s'était
même quelque chose de prévu par les
modèles qui a vu qu'ils ont été libérés
en place qui au passage prévoyait cinq
cent mille morts or cette deuxième vague
qui aurait dû venir immédiatement cette
deuxième vague n'est pas venu alors
qu'on nous avait prévenus que ça allait
revenir et que tu théoriquement elle
aurait dû revenir
or elle n'est pas venue et on l'attend
toujours
et ça j'aimerais bien avoir une
explication j'avais déjà j'avais des 10
lorsqu'on a mis en place ce confinement
j'ai eu personnellement très peur
puis je me suis dit si la deuxième vague
n'arrive pas il faudra très sérieusement
réfléchir à l'efficacité de ce
confinement et bien je vous demande de
confinement alors réponse antoine
flahault m'aviez dit je vous avais posé
la question puisque vous m'aviez dit à
l'époque
c'est une méthode médiéval le
confinement mais enfin bon on en a pas
d'autres et vous m'avez dit sur le plan
sanitaire ça a plutôt réussi vous le
toujours vous pensez toujours
bah oui je pense que c'est la
démonstration c'est le ce répit estival
que l'on a pu tous connaître en europe
où l'on a appliqué le déconfinement qu'à
partir du moment où on était en vrai des
crues quant au mois de mai on a décidé
de descons fine et la france mais c'est
également vrai pour la suisse ou
l'allemagne l'espagne ou l'italie
eh bien on est est en décrue très
affirmée et je pense pour ma part que le
frein estivale a été très bénéfique nous
a accompagnés tout l'été en particulier
qu'il n'y a pas eu en effet de
recrudescence de cette mortalité
je pense très sincèrement grâce à ce
frein estivale les pays qui n'ont pas le
frein estivale c'est pas un blocage
estivale c'est à dire que on sait que ça
réduit de 40% à peu près la force de
transmission le fameux air 0 dans le cas
de la grippe mais la grippe par pas très
haut son aise 0 excusez moi c'est un peu
technique mais sur les 0 par de 1,5 donc
40% de deux mois c'est à dire
06 25 ans tombe à un peu moins de 1 et
on a pas d'épidémie de grippe endettés
mais pour le coronavirus sa part de
beaucoup plus haut on est à 2 5 ou 3 le
r0 donc si vous faites la même force que
celle de la grippe parce que c'est un
virus respiratoires c'est tout à fait
possible
alors ce cette force estivale elle ne
suffit pas arrêtée à bloquer des
épidémies c'est ce qui s'est passé aux
états unis dans l'hémisphère nord
il ya eu en effet des épidémies assez
forte qui n'ont pas été contrôlés
ce que l'on voit c'est le pendant du
frein estivale c'est ce qui s'est passé
encore une fois dans l'hémisphère sud et
dans l'hémisphère sud ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui ils sont en plein hiver
ils connaissent
les épidémies extrêmement fortes et des
deuxième vague pour certains comme
l'australie une vague hivernale très
forte
donc je dirais l'australie en confinant
melbourne se trouve avoir complètement
contrôler le processus
le pérou pauvre pérou qui a beaucoup de
mal à confiner son pays qui ne peut pas
confiné lorsque la plupart des gens ne
peuvent pas simplement aller en en
confinement parce qu'ils doivent nourrir
leurs familles et que même malade il
continue à être dans la communauté se
perd ou connaît une vague qui ne cesse
d'augmenter
je dirais que partout où un confinement
précoce a été mise en place et où il a
été maintenu suffisamment longtemps pour
que le la décrue apparaissent alors il à
éviter l'engorgement des hôpitaux il à
éviter l'excès de mortalité et il a
fonctionné
je ne veux pas du tout faire l'apologie
du fond du confinement c'est en effet
archaïque et médiévale comme comme on
l'avait dit d'ensemble c'est la dernière
chose à faire maintenant la déteste on a
des tonnes d une possibilité de tracer
les personnes on a aussi les contacts
on a aussi des des masques de protection
on a aussi des éléments qui peuvent nous
permettre le télétravail c'était pas
possible autrefois maintenant c'est
possible on peut promouvoir des
solutions qui sont qui vont nous éviter
le plus longtemps possible
le confinement mais en effet je pense
que il y a beaucoup beaucoup de niveaux
de preuve aujourd'hui pour affirmer que
ce confinement a été très dur et le
dernier point que je voudrais rajouter
c'est que je suis d'accord avec laurent
toubiana que c'est difficile à entendre
de dire tel peuple serait plus je dirais
enclin à suivre
spontanément des mesures de santé
publique que d'autres bon c'est un fait
que les peuples du nord sont plus
enclins à suivre les mesures de santé
publique parce que la culture est plus
ancrée parce que l'éducation on
sanitaire a été plus ancrée je pense que
il ya des différences entre les peuples
germaniques elle n'est pas plus latin
pour vous dire genève s'est comporté à
peu près comme la france alors que
zurich et que la suisse alémanique s'est
comporté beaucoup plus comme l'autriche
et comme l'allemagne
ça nous fait réfléchir c'est assez
intéressant c'est un jugement
il n'y a pas de jugement de valeur là
dessus mais je pense qu il est vrai
qu'on a sans doute des approches
culturelles de la santé publique et de
la prévention qui peuvent être un peu
différente entre les peuples d'europe et
que on peut peut-être gagné et a essayé
d'écouter parce que on n'a pas envie en
tout cas d'un confinement strict qui ne
sera imposée à nouveau avec une
assignation à résidence comme on l'a
connu on aimerait beaucoup plus d'être
participatif y compris dans les pays
latins dernière question pour élise
clément frutos le quotidien les échos
annoncé que le virus avait muté qu'il
était devenu plus contagieux mais moins
dangereux
est-ce que vous en avez entendu parler
ça a été relayée par plusieurs chaînes
de télévision est ce que vous avez
constatez vous même cette mutation ou
est ce qu'elle ne sort on ne sait d'où
il connaissait absolument pas confirmé
on a quand même l'impression d'avoir
affaire à un virus qui a une capacité de
mutation assez faible il n'a pas dû
évoluer énormément en six mois
il est très très contagieux donc ça on
le sait donc il reste très contagieux
qu'il soit moins virulent
ça n'est pas ça n'est pas confirmée
encore d'accord tous les trois l'euro
tombé en arrêt il n'a pas muté ce virus
un mois sur le sur la mutation des virus
les virus vivent leur vie et ça ne
m'intéresse pas trop je peux vous dire
parce que ce qui m'intéresse c'est autre
chose
ce qui m'intéresse et l'épidémiologie
dans son camp sa manière dans son sa
compréhension transversale j'observe que
effectivement même trois secondes en
suède en s'auto con on s'auto confine
mais on en suède
on réfléchit au bénéfice risque des
mesures que l'on met en place et ça pour
moi c'est extrêmement important
voilà c'est ce que je voulais rajouter
j'aime beaucoup
antoine flahault avec lequel j'ai
beaucoup travaillé et j'adore l'écouter
donc j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion
encore une fois de se rencontrer
merci tous les trois d'avoir participé à
cette première émission de la rentrée
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]